صينيه افضت الى فتح ابواب العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران مجددا بعد توقف زاد على
سبع سنوات شهدت الاربع الاخيره منها جوله
عده من الحوار كلانتها مفاوضات بكين
باتفاق على فتح السفارتين بين البلدين في
غضون شهرين اثر تحقق المطالب السعوديه
الاتفاق جاء استجابه لمبادره من الرئيس
الصيني
لتطوير علاقات حسن الجوار بين الرياض
وطهران بعد الاستعداد الذي ابدته ايران
للدخول في مفاوضات بناءه تقود الى استعاده
العلاقه بعد ان قطعها هجوم على السفاره
السعوديه بطهران وقنصليتها في مشهد في
يناير عام 2016
عوده العلاقات بين البلدين تاتي نتيجه
لجوله من الحوار بدات اولاها في ديسمبر
2019 في العراق كاول حوار مباشر منذ قطع
العلاقات عام 2022 اجر البلدان 5 جولات من
الحوار اخرها عقد في ابريل 2022 ببغداد في
حين لعبت سلطنه عمان دورا غير مباشر
لتقريب وجهات النظر بين العامين
و2022
البيان الثنائي لعوده العلاقات قام ان
المباحثات التي سبقت الاعلان جرت بين
السادس والعاشر من الشهر الجاري في بكين
بين وفدي السعوديه وايران برئاسه مستشار
الامن الوطني السعودي سعد العباد وامين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني علي
شمخاني الاتفاق تضمن تاكيد البلدين على
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه ومناقشه سبل التعزيز العلاقات
وبذل كل الجهود لتعزيز السلم والامن
الاقليمي والدولي استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران سيتلوه
حسب الاتفاق تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الامني
بين البلدين واتفاقيه التعاون بينهما في
مجال الاقتصاد وتجاره والاستثمار والتقنيه
والعلوم والثقافه والرياضه
وسلطه الصين واستضافتها للمباحثات جاءت
مكملتين للاتفاقيه الاقتصاديه التي
ابرمتها مع دول المنطقه التي تضم ممرات
بحريه استراتيجيه للاقتصاد العالمي